20 tons of new trash each day 50
truckloads of garbage are delivered to
the waste incineration plant tune on
over before it's burned it gets sorted
according to size liquid content and
weight by plant employee Carsten Milka
we have to make sure that it doesn't Jam
when I insert the waste it slides down a
shaft and when it's too thick it can
sometimes get stuck a constant
incineration temperature of at least 850
degrees Celsius is important so that the
energy contained in the waste can be
turned into electricity the facility in
Hannover can provide power to 57
households that's important to the
production director his goal is low
emissions and wasting as little
resources as possible instead of simply
letting water drain it's collected the
entire site is connected to a system so
all the water here is collected
processed and reused in the plant German
companies are known for the highest
environmental standards and the plans
Managing Director is certain that's
exactly what convinced Chinese investors
to acquire the German waste processing
company the employees know-how gives
them confidence so they're not worried
about the company having new owners
we're talking about the construction of
new plants and that's where II W has a
lot of experience we've built and
planned many facilities in Germany in
recent years and are operating them
today that is of course an area of
expertise that we can really use for our
current expansion in Europe the Chinese
investors want to focus on growth
Beijing enterprises is a large state-run
conglomerate but EWS managing director
insists that won't affect the company's
employees in Germany lots of people are
asking what they can do to get familiar
with Chinese culture are the courses we
can take to learn how to give someone a
business card or to say hello or what
can we do when we're eating meals
together things like that it's happening
voluntarily and that's a good thing
officially the purchase was agreed upon
at the beginning of March for a
record-breaking 1.4 billion euros
knowing how to incinerate waste can be
very lucrative China will be building
over 1,000 new plants in the coming
years China is a huge country and
garbage is a problem development is
lagging behind that of Central Europe
that's why China is determined to
develop these technologies and bring
them up to the highest level but when it
comes to limits emissions and
environmental protection China is still
far away from meeting German standards
like here in Hannover